un panorama desolador tras un ataque
ruso a la ciudad de gersón recuperada
recientemente por las fuerzas de
kievero ahí
de aquí sacamos creo que a 4 o 5
pacientes gravemente heridos dos de un
hotel y dos cuadras más abajo la mayoría
de las personas estaban muertas
el primer ataque golpeó a los grandes
almacenes aquí el segundo golpeó el
mercado la gente dice que murieron más
personas allí y también un ataque cerca
de dos tiendas es una pena que haya
muerto gente
un funcionario acusó a las tropas
ucranianas de montar el ataque para
inculpar a los rusos Ucrania se
recuperaba del bombardeo Invasor a gran
escala del pasado lunes Esta no es la
primera vez que Moscú ataca gersón desde
su repliegue a los márgenes del río
nipro por su parte el presidente
ucraniano voló
un mensaje de navidad a sus ciudadanos
el mandatario hizo referencia
dificultades que traen consigo los
ataques rusos a la infraestructura
crítica nacional
[Música]
cantaremos villancicos con más alegría
que nunca para que sea más fuerte que el
sonido del generador escucharemos las
voces y los saludos de nuestros seres
queridos en nuestras almas Incluso si la
conexión a internet se cae Incluso en la
más completa oscuridad nos encontraremos
para abrazarnos con fuerza y si no hay
calor nos abrazaremos durante mucho
tiempo para calentarnos
días atrás el kremlin dio a conocer que
a pesar de los festejos por Navidad las
operaciones militares no se detendrían